guys have you ever played a game where
you're crushing your opponents so badly
you kind of just stop playing for real
and start you know blacks in on oh well
I haven't because I suck but I can
imagine what that feels like with this
list of the top 10 ways to flex on them
in eSports starting us off is the
feeling of absolute domination you get
when you win a full eco round against a
full buy is dragon trying to shut it
down - aggressive approach to kills
missile gun rock is just suits fracas
well map for two now at all falls apart
this is a full eco pretty much what in
God's name has just happened it takes
everything that makes a csgo player
great tactics communication and of
course insane aim with that pistol so
once again spread out and try to play a
little bit more slowly on this run will
be a fully go from CLG so not expecting
any massive upsets here okay well that's
a great start they take down the V play
oh oh no we just come on you know that's
actually insane dude there's few things
in counter-strike more satisfying than
destroying your opponent while they have
the economic advantage I mean when the
other team is locked and loaded with
everything the game from Kevlar to Auto
snipers to nades and you still end up on
top that's a real flex taking the number
nine spot is proof that even a troll
pick can be a flex it could be ganked a
lot sword
welcome to the main event for the hero
everyone loves to hate and hates the
love there is no hero more infuriating
and sadistic in all of dota than techies
and while people hate playing against
those stupid goblins succeeding with
techies is actually kind of a flex when
that heroes in the game only he's having
fun that's how I feel about it
and did you have fun playing of course
he's super fun winning with techies
requires a galaxy brain level knowledge
of the game and there's nothing quite as
satisfying as watching your opponent's
struggle to find any foothold on a map
littered with mines and fear this time
c-deck is saying you're gonna play
around us we reinforcements are here the
call has been made vici gaming could
have just kite out a neo slowly take
away they're just making it to the mine
Thursday please no Jarek save us
anything okay rocket League is full of
sick shots made by incredible
freestylers but the biggest flex of the
ball might just be the ceiling shot
which is why it takes the number-8 spot
on our list
season and he pulls it off here in the
most clutch moments but player to invent
the shot now there are two different
ways you could play rocket League
you can play optimally with the sole
intent of winning or you can play for
pure style and there's no better way to
do that than with the ceiling shot a
ceiling shot tells those worthless
scrubs that no matter what you will get
the ball in the back of the net there's
nothing they can do about it to the
ground open up the series coming in at
number seven is the ultimate way to flex
on your opponents in fighting games
stylish combos
oh joy
sometimes all it takes to end around is
a couple of hits but if you really want
to send your opponent to the Shadow
Realm you got a style on them some of
these combos take insane skill to pull
off and it's all the sweeter knowing
that your opponent is just sitting there
waiting for you to finish flexing
wow great confirmed cine medium called
you plasma beam canceled in the paper
and site exchange Wow in the middle of
the screen like that huh nut what
and this man swag any harder style
combos are all about unnecessary
extensions not because it'll do more
damage to your opponent's life bar but
because it will do the kind of mental
damage that a regular combo could never
accomplish buying more than a few ops is
the definitive way to flex on your
opponent at the end of a game of CS and
it takes the number six spot on our list
look at the guns Oh
aw peas they're ready to shoot some
ducks as they cross the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and
not in this lifetime he is destroyed
sometimes depending on the state of the
economy a game is basically over before
the last round is even played and
there's no better way to make that point
than buying as many offs as possible
five bombs for MIP are on this 505 just
having functions around yeah this isn't
dust to look at ferns for now T side
five ops look at fern falling there
double head stacked in this little
kitchen area towards the inner area this
is actually hilarious rolling up to the
last round with five ops up 15 Oh is how
you flex just how much money your team
has earned you're flashing all that cash
you got from round after round of
systematically destroying the enemy team
and the results can be absolutely
hilarious fnatic right now they just
don't care they've got 11 rounds on CT
side cobble the second kill or flush the
Xu's crouches right into the angle and
how do not be realized what's going on
do they start to like did they actually
get 5 ops against us there's no way at
the halfway point on our list is your
squad rolling up to the server with
matching skins
[Applause]
when your team shows up with a matching
set of skins for each of your champions
the other team immediately knows things
are about to get real not only are you
proving that your squad is coordinated
you're also letting them know that
you're willing to shell out cash for
what really matters fashion and the
biggest flex of the mall is rolling up
in skins made specifically for you I
mean come on is there anything scarier
that SKT playing in their own world
skins
there's no fashion statement in gaming
that's more of a flex than that coming
in at the number four spot is the kind
of flex only a true Greek god could pull
off zhuzhing someone in csgo now they're
gonna try to execute in here comes tarik
now he's got the ceased in hand will we
steam connect and there we go just walks
right up shuts it down Eddie finds a
second kill with the smg2 takedown
summit as well how much could they have
possibly prepared you're a madman soos
out instead and looking to get a little
bit closer in there this mix walk-on
they picked up gonna get one more counts
can even comes right into a tarik with a
huge double kill more than any other
weapon in csgo the Zeus tests your
confidence and your skill you have to
have the perfect read on where your
opponent is going to be on the map you
have to have the confidence to hold that
extremely tight angle and if you even
make one mistake you're dead and you
wasted your money but if you make it
work well nothing feels better so they
might go for him
he knows that as well Terry's just
around the corner
let's see I was waiting for that taking
the number three spot on our list is the
greatest flex in dota2 stealing the
aegis does he want to make the big plays
he's dropped an item and he's thinking
about it
they've got social vision and any job
[Applause]
now imagine how the enemy team feels
after they do all the work of winning
the team fight and whittling down Roshan
only to see you swoop in and steal what
was rightfully theirs if there's like a
crystal Nova and a frost bite you might
be able to get away from this poor that
ends up killing him but that failed they
thought the epic game in the bag they
did not account for you you go in steal
that Aegis and before you know it you
just left the enemy team awestruck by
your skill and bravery for the steel
rush in the pit fighting on two dead and
the chase now going straight on the th
make it three absolute catastrophe in
Rainbow six siege there is only one true
flex locking in to Chaka and absolutely
annihilating your opponents with him and
that's why this is taking the number two
spot on our list how he's wearing the
chalk at home don't do my immersion
right now all-time high
my god to chunka is okay the worst
operator and siege but there are a
select few who want to grace the server
with the Lord's good word we surely
gonna see yeah okay we're gonna say to
chant constructors I'm sure you've got
plenty of information about those in
your pocket so I'll let you talk to us
sorry about all the research I've done
that fact laughs forgive me on my knees
praying for the lords usually picking
tachanka is a troll pick an easy way to
piss off your teammates and your enemies
but in the hands of two ChaCha's chosen
warriors he becomes the ultimate flex
there's nothing quite like mowing down
your enemies with a giant stupid turret
while they wonder what's even going on
through some pills a few okay
[Music]
yes taking the top spot on our list is
the ultimate flex in competitive gaming
the pure mechanical power move that is
out playing a gank you're gonna try and
kill the plate before dropping rip or
maybe just kill something looks like the
dive could be the choice here
I'll see coming up in the kalon too
Wiggly he wants to dive through by the
execution they see down a 2v1 after the
enemy jungler pops out of the shadows
coming for your throat
is a terrifying experience but
swallowing that fear and fighting back
is a true test of skill and a chance to
[ __ ] your opponent's egos it's pure
knowledge it's pure skill it's taking an
unwinnable situation and winning and
it's a god-like flex and once you've
either killed them or sent them running
back to base they're left wondering if
they should even be playing the game I
mean hell after that maybe they should
just uninstall yeah they probably should
sigh oh my goodness the shy going right
back yesterday Russia walks up the a day
carry magic it's gonna get nothing wrong
with them I can't believe the shy right
now that's a one feed three with two
soul kills well guys that about does it
for the top 10 ways to flex on your
opponents in eSports now if you're
looking to feel more thick and pumped in
the immortal words of Dick Stacy head on
over to twitch.tv slash the score
eSports and go ahead and squat that
follow button and listen if you haven't
subscribed to this YouTube channel
already I'm gonna need to ask you to
clean and jerk the sub button and while
you're at it bench press the like button
and I don't know curl in the comments or
something
alright well in today's video we talked
about flexing on them so for the N board
on this one I mean I want to show you
guys something that no bodybuilding
library is complete without the arnold
schwarzenegger encyclopedia a
bodybuilding talk about thick and pomp
look at this thing it's basically uh
both the philosophical and a scientific
reflection by arnold on bodybuilding and
how to do it and why to do and all that
kind of stuff but my favorite thing is
basically the pictures that illustrate
the culture of bodybuilding back in the
1970s and 80s and and decades
surrounding that you know in venice
beach and places like that it's pretty
cool cultural artifact